[Music]
samsung is going big this year with the
upcoming launch of the new samsung
galaxy s20 series
as the name suggests the s20 is what the
korean tech giant hopes to be the
beginning of a new era for its flagship
smartphones and as we've learned at the
samsung unpacked event earlier this week
there'll be three variants for the
samsung galaxy s20 the base s20 the s20
plus
and the s20 ultra so geek culture
managed to get a first look at the
galaxy s20 series so let's check out
what's new
[Music]
so probably the biggest upgrade for the
s20 series is the camera
so if you have used the samsung galaxy
flagship phone before you know that it
comes with really great cameras and the
s20 is no different the base s20 and s20
plus both come with a 64 megapixel
camera with up to three times hybrid
optical zoom and up to 30 times digital
zoom what takes the cake here is the
cameras on the s20 ultra which has a
main camera that spots a whopping 108
megapixels this means you'll be able to
zoom in quite a lot on the images you
take without having to compromise on
quality so you might be wondering why is
samsung opting for such a high pixel
count on its main camera well if you're
a photographer or somebody who just
likes to snap pictures all day this
might be a perfect alternative for dslr
without having to carry the bulk around
furthermore the s20 ultra comes with a
telephoto lens of up to 100 times
digital zoom
this makes it great for capturing images
that are really really far away
or spying on other people don't don't
quote us on that while the s20 series is
clearly great for photography it's also
pretty great at video recording and is
capable of recording footage of up to 8k
at 30 frames per second but that's not
all for the s20s camera it also comes
with the single take mode which allows
you to snap up to 14 different images
videos and gifs with the single press of
the shutter
while it's not the most groundbreaking
feature singletake is quite the time
saver as it minimizes the need to switch
between different shooting modes
especially if you want something quick
and snappy aside from the camera the
display is also another improvement that
samsung has made on the s20 series these
new models come with the option to
toggle between 60hz and a buttery smooth
120hz refresh rate coupled with a
beautiful amoled infinity o curve
display
this makes the animations on your
operating system feel a lot smoother and
fluid and it does make it feel a lot
faster as you use it couple that with a
new exynos 990 chipset and up to 12
gigabytes of ram you have yourself quite
a powerful device storage wise the s20
series comes with a base 128 gigabytes
with up to 512 gigabytes for the s20
ultra and up to an additional one
terabyte of expandable storage and if
that's not all the s20 series comes with
5g variants with the s20 ultra already a
native 5g device while it isn't
immediately significant it's a great way
to future proof yourself as carriers
still look to expand their 5g networks
especially since you're paying a premium
for your new smartphone you're
definitely not losing out in the coming
years the samsung galaxy s20 series
releases in singapore on the 6th of
march 2020. the galaxy s20 will retail
for 1298 singapore dollars
the s20 plus will retail for
1498 singapore dollars
and the s20 ultra will retail for
1898 singapore dollars
if you want to find out a more detailed
breakdown of the pricing specs and user
experience of the galaxy s20 series you
can find it on the link in the
description below